Hi Everyone,
this is Evan pushback and it's my first
video blog.
I think I'm gonna have to learn how to
not look at myself in the picture so
much.
Uh,
I'm just drawn to my face.
I'm a writer,
a much like John Green of the vlog
brothers.
Uh,
I am a nerdfighter to,
uh,
unlike John Green.
However,
I'm not published.
I did it again.
I just looked at myself in the picture.
I can't help it.
Do I move my face down to the very,
very corner of the screen.
I promise I will try not to look at it
one more time for the rest of this
video.
I know I've been told by people that I
do that when I talk to them on skype or
any other kind of video chat,
I'm trying to figure out what I should
do for my first flog a.
I had been thinking about a lot of
ideas.
I figured a good idea might be to start
with telling me a little about myself a
little bit.
What I do and the reason that I wanted
to start a blog in the first place.
Well,
my name is Evan Puschak.
That's who?
Then Shaq.
Um,
yeah,
my childhood was tough living in Los
Angeles.
Like I said,
I'm a writer.
I write novels.
I studied film making in Boston for for
many,
many years now.
I don't do that anymore.
It's a couple reasons.
I'm not still in the filmmaking
industry.
Um,
I still love the art of filmmaking.
A lot of my friends still do it and I
encouraged them to be the best that they
can edit.
Um,
and I still love talking about it wasn't
so much that I didn't like the business
side of the industry.
Electrical say,
Oh,
you got to be a bitch for this many
years getting coffee and so on,
so forth.
You know,
that's tough.
But I didn't really mind that so much.
What am I did?
Was that film making is an art form that
is enmeshed in money and you can't
unmeasured.
Does that measure word?
I don't think so.
What it means is this is if you're
really fast,
you can maybe maybe make for short films
a year.
And I'm talking about conception from
the,
from the writing process onto the final
edit.
You maybe do four a year,
so if you're a and you sort of know that
when you have an idea for a project,
it's like a vision inside of your head.
It might be triggered by a song or a
story or buy something that you say,
but it triggers in your head like a
vision,
like a dream.
And then the process of filmmaking from
writing to casting,
to filming to editing.
It's all sort of a process of the
degradation of that first idea.
Now a lot of people like that.
A lot of people would say that it's sort
of a maturation of an idea that happens
in your head to something that is
definitely going to be different,
but could,
could well be better.
Also,
a lot of people like the idea of working
together with a lot of people to make a
project.
Um,
you know,
because cooperation is the thing that
they get into it for now.
I like cooperation.
Don't get me wrong in my life with my
friends,
with my family,
with the people that I love.
I am willing to cooperate with them on
act of living on the process of living.
I want you to help me and I'm going to
help you and we're going to get along
together the best we can.
We're going to be the best people that
we can,
but when it comes to my art,
it's a whole different story.
I confess to being a fascist.
Now granted,
I think that don't make it does require
a dictator,
benevolent dictator,
and I try to be in Neverland dictator.
It just still wasn't at the level of
control that I needed for art.
You're saying all this at the risk of
sounding pretentious,
but I think that that risk is worth
taking and I also think that potential
is a pretty ugly word.
When is that?
I had sort of falling out with
filmmaking.
I left that and over the process of a
few months I sort of reevaluate what I
wanted and I realized that I didn't want
to be an artist.
I didn't want to create,
but once they're a different art form
that would maybe suit me better.
So I tried writing first I tried,
you know,
writing short story and then I tried
writing a novella.
Finally I tried writing a novel just to
see if I had the stamina to put that
many words to paper that I did have the
stamina and that I loved it and also
that it gave me the opportunity to
cuddle my work and the way that I want
to.
You can sort of coddle a sentence or
paragraph in the in a way that you can't
with a,
a film shot for example.
So there we are.
So I went to Paris for the summer.
I wrote my first novel.
I'm revising it now and we get to the
reason why I am starting this blog
because I'm as video editing,
but mostly because I see blogging as a
good platform to get my word out there.
Someone expressed to me.
It was actually a distant cousin who is
a writer.
He wrote an email to me and he said,
you know,
the dilemma is being famous before
you're famous,
and I thought that was a really good way
of putting it,
you know,
I saw John Green and hank green and I
started to watch the vlog where those
videos and I was inspired by them,
but mostly I was inspired by the
community of nerdfighteria.
I just had this feeling that maybe a lot
of you have to,
that you know,
the future of art and expression is
going to be within these communities
that are built online and elsewhere
where people from all over the world can
get together and share what they did and
I started thinking I'm willing to
support anybody in nerdfighteria who's
got something to show some form of
expression,
whether,
whether it's art or science,
any of these things.
As long as there's some merit to it and
you know,
America comes from practice and practice
and practice.
It's not.
Everything's good.
Not Everybody's going to be good for the
people who are and they're a part of my
community.
I'm gonna support you because that's
what a community is.
Now.
I'm hoping this,
maybe it's like I get myself,
you know,
I don't know how old this publishing
thing is going to work.
I'm going into the breach when I'm done
revising this book and I hope that
something can come of it.
I hope that it's a good book.
I guess you'll tell me that you'll be
the judge of that,
but thank you for watching my video.
Thank you.
John Green and hank green and all
nerdfighteria for being part of this.
That was.
I looked at myself again.